all right now let's turn to another
crisis brewing inside the biden
administration that is the crisis that
is known as competence tonight with a
steady stream of resignation the vice
president's office is in a state of
turmoil this has many other former and
current staffers are now complaining
about what they describe as a mean
hostile work environment according to
reports multiple individuals describing
kamala harris as a quote
soul-destroying bully who frequently is
lashing out at her own staff for her own
failures here with reaction from the
trump organization eric trump you know
so joe is in the mid-30s you know in
terms of approval kamala's even lower
than that 28
is not a single thing i think they can
point to eric that says oh this this is
really working we're doing a really good
job here unless you could point it out
no that's right i mean listen sean you
know try and be a white house com
staffer when you can't deliver a single
victory not not a single policy victory
you've got the worst inflation that
we've seen in 30 years you've got a
horrible jobs number you saw that 210
000 jobs the worst jobs number we've
seen in a long time as you just pointed
out china and taiwan russia trying to
take ukraine mess on the southern border
i mean where do you want me to stop
ramping crime all across this country
right people still you know massively
out of work in this country
i mean it's it's a disaster it's a they
don't have a single thing that they have
accomplished they don't have a single
thing that they've done well and you
know what a very easy you know secret
people want to pay play for the winning
team right
there are no wins these people aren't
delivering any wins if this is a losing
team and it's not shocking that they
know biden won't run again they know
kamala is no longer kind of the darling
child that she used to be
and so what's their future in in the
white house they probably want to go
back into private industry which i
completely understand and that's why
people are fleeing you know left and
right
you know
there's no doubt
every hostile regime studies the united
states
they have concluded the obvious and that
is that joe biden is in a serious
significant precipitous cognitive
decline now we can also see nancy pelosi
struggling herself when it comes to her
ability to communicate then we got third
in and you know a little out of order
but the vice president that is not
clearly not up to the job
so now
all these hostile regimes as we were
just discussing want to take full
advantage of a weak america
and with no real leadership and no
ability seemingly to to engage in a way
that would be significant to anybody's
benefit
yeah that's right and they all disappear
you know i always say why is it that
this administration always disappears
you have pete bootage right whenever
there's a crisis at the ports guess what
he's on
paternity leave and you know kamala
harris who's supposed to be taking care
of the southern border guess what she
goes over to vietnam when there's a
crisis on the southern border and joe
biden's in wilmington delaware when
afghanistan is literally being taken by
terrorists who three weeks ago were
riding
mopeds around the place right i mean
these people don't show up they don't
put any fight into this country they
don't have the energy they don't have
the gravitas right i mean and they're
constantly losing because their policy
positions are always wrong and you
better believe that you know leaders
around the world and these are
aggressive people right you know chi and
putin all these guys they are going to
test this guy because they sense a
weakness they can smell the weakness
they never saw that under donald trump
donald trump always stood up to these
people he would put massive sanctions on
china he would stand up to russia he
would give javelin missiles to the
ukrainians so he they could take care of
me
ever came over that border and
you know your dad better than anybody is
your dad going to run in 2024
well listen i'm not going to say that
sean but you know what i certainly hope
he does as a son and as a person who
loves this country i certainly hope he
does because honestly this country can't
take more of this nonsense i mean we
need real leadership this isn't
toughness this is an american
strength you know i mean people around
the world are laughing at this guy
they're laughing at this administration
we better get tough otherwise we're not
going to have a country again
and i'll tell you eric it's real it's
humiliating it's really embarrassing um
anyway eric trump great to see you thank
you as always
i'm steve ducey i'm brian kilny and i'm
ainsley erhardt and click here to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis